e
ont été accusé d'agressé
sexuellement une adolescente
Alexandre Gascon.
- Un autre cas d'agression
junior, cette fois dans la LHJMQ
à Drummondville. Trois jeunes
hommes, dont deux mineurs,
sont accusés d'avoir commis
un viol collectif  2 2 2 2 2 2 .
Dans cette histoire de viol
allégué, deux s s trois
participants étaient mineurs
et ont plaidé coupable devant
le tribunaititititititititititie
par les tribunaux.
Le troisième, Noah Corson,
18 ans à l'époque, clame
son innocence en atten L L L L t
le fils de l'ancien joueur
du Canadien de Montréal
Shayne Corson.
MARTIN LECLERCenenenenenenenenes
du hockey junior en général
sont un peu dépassés
par ce phénomène-là.
- À Ottawa, on s'ckckckckckckcky
est culturel, pense-t-on.
ALALALE ST-ONGE,
ministre fédérale des Sports
- Qu'on n'est pas dans
vraiment d'une culture qui est
imprégnée dans le monde
du hockey, qui va demander
l'implication de tout le monde
qui sont i d d d d d d d d d d s
du hockey.
- Pour la LHJMQ, l'enjeu dépasse
largement le cadre sportif.
MAXIME BLOUIN,uéuéuéuéuéuéuéuéuc
- Je pense que nous, oui,
on a un rdudududucatif à faire
auprès de nos joueurs,
mais je pense que la société
auàààààààààààààààààààààààààààààs
pour les sensibiliser,
finalement, à ces enjeux
de violence sexuelle.
- Le fédéral réclame
Certains observateurs aussi.
fofofoformations pour les joueu,
évidemment, mais aussi pour
les entraîneurs, les dirigeant .
MICHELLE COURCHESNE, ancienn
min. Éducation, Loisir et Sport
- Pourquoi? Parce que ces gens-
une sorte de bulle. Ils sont
souvnsnsnsns les autobus,
ils font souvent des activités
entre eux. Mais il faut que ça
de toutes les organisations i is
se sentent à l'aise d'aborder
ces sujets-là.ieieieieieieieiei,
qui coûte cher à réaliser.
La ligue affirme avoir besoin
de l'aide des paliers
de gouvernements.
La LHJMQ salue la collaboration
se buter au silence à Ottawa.
Léa Clermont-Dion a donné
des ateliers sur le consentement
cet automne. Elle souhaite
que la sensibilisation
devienne la norme.
postdoctorante, Univ. Concordia
- Ça prend une volonté
politique. Elle existe,
je crois. Mais particulièrement
lenteur avant d'agir.
Là, je pense qu'il y a u
Il faut vraiment prendre acte
du problème et réagir.
que commencer.
Ici Alexandre Gascon,
Radio-Canada, à Montréa